[Musik]
bomben ohne ende tausende tote seit vier
monaten mittlerweile krieg und doch
sagen millionen deutsche davon wollen
wir nichts mehr wissen die eigenen
sorgen die eigenen probleme wie das
tanken die inflation usw sind einfach
offenbar zu groß krieg ohne ende aber
endet auch unsere hilfe darüber
diskutieren wir jetzt hier die richtigen
fragen an diese gäste an antje hermenau
die ex grüne hier bei uns zu gast sie
wirft ihrer ex partei mittlerweile
kriegs stürme rey vor anton hofreiter
der
grünen-bundestagsabgeordnete er sagt wer
pazifist ist der macht genau das jetzt
der schickt eben auch panzer und peggy
lindemann ist bei uns aus spezies
laboranten in der raffinerie in schwedt
dort wo putins öl ankommt also ihr job
hängt an putins öl und sie möchte auch
dass genau das so bleibt der ukrainische
botschafter in deutschland ist bei uns
andrej melik der sieht das alles ganz
anders und fordert weitere deutsche
waffenlieferungen endlich sagt er und ha
schult der künstler aktions kanzler ist
bei uns eher strikt dagegen fordert die
aktion kanzler aktions kanzler erfordert
den kann das lernen nämlich aufderhaar
schuld keine schweren waffen in die
ukraine zu liefern ihnen allen schönen
guten abend hier bei bils bei den
richtigen fragen einig dass gerade schon
gesagt sie fordern schwere waffen das
ist seit wochen seit monaten ihre
forderung keine einzige schwere waffe
hat deutschland bisher in die ukraine
geliefert tragen wir alle hier mit am
tisch damit eine verantwortung auch
dafür für viele tote in ihrem land so
sehen dass meine landsleute und ich
glaube dass auch die deutschen sich
gedanken machen sollten ob sie
tatsächlich bereit sind auch diese
schuld auf sich zu laden denn dieser
krieg wird früher oder schneller vorbei
sein und dann stellt sich die frage wer
war auf unserer seite und wer hat nur
zugesehen und es gibt keine zwischentöne
es gibt noch schwarz und weiß und da
muss man sich entscheiden und nicht nur
sagen nicht nur versprechen was wir
hören sondern auch wirklich tun und
liefern und deswegen
davon hängt ab wie viele ukraine nicht
sterben müssen er schuld sind sie bereit
er schuld diese schuld auf sich zu laden
wie herr may nicht gerade sagte oder
können sie immer offen ins gesicht sagen
warum sie dagegen sind gegen neue
lieferung von waffen vermelden ich bin
ein wirklicher fan wie sie irland in
unserem land vertreten aber ich bin auch
ein bürger dieses landes das müssen sie
einfach verstehen
und ich habe das letzte wort von unserer
kanzlerin immer noch in den ohren
bei olaf scholz da kann nicht ruhig
schlafen sie beide wurden von ihnen sehr
kräftig attackiert ich finde das passt
nicht zu unserem gespräch aber laden sie
diese wenig sagt schult auf sicher
schuld wenn sie jetzt den kanzler ganz
offen auffordern das sein zu lassen mit
lieferung schwerer waffen deshalb völlig
blödsinnig dieser dieses argument ist
völlig aus dem von irgendwoher gegriffen
kein deutscher trägt schuld daran was in
der ukraine geschieht entschuldigen sie
bitte das ist so eine unmögliche
behauptung dass hier aufzustellen in
einer öffentlichen sendung wir deutsche
haben andere schuld noch zu verteidigen
von unserer generation zu der ich
übrigens fast schon gehörig wenn dir
dieser stadt in den trümmern
aufgewachsen ich hab die stalin orgel
noch in erinnerung ich war ein thriller
kind berlin sah so aus wie die bilder
die man jetzt hier von der ukraine zeigt
aber ich bin dagegen mit waffen zu töten
erwischen da bin ich wirklich dagegen
herr hofreiter sie sagen wenn man sich
als pazifist versteht muss man jetzt das
gegenteil von dem tun was herr schuld
gerade sagt dann muss man engagiert
seine muss man waffen liefern ich habe
mich erstens nie als pazifist verstanden
und des weiteren gibt es bei uns grünen
in dem bereich einfach unterschiedliche
wurzeln auf der einen seite die
friedensbewegung und auf der anderen
seite aber was entgegen schuld hier ein
sehr menschenrechte und
das ist ja total vereinfacht gesagt denn
die ukraine hat er den krieg nicht
angefangen
die ukraine hat sich ja nicht ausgesucht
sich wehren zu müssen
und es geht hier nicht darum zu sagen
mehr waffen liefert tötet sondern die
russische armee tötet sie malt sie
vergewaltigt und wenn man dann sagt man
unterstützt das opfer nicht dann ist das
schlichtweg unterlassene hilfeleistung
und nicht pazifismus sondern pazifismus
ist wenn man sich für sich selbst
entscheiden das muss ich nicht wert sei
aber das opfer im stich zu lassen zu
unterlassen sagt der grüne
bundestagsabgeordnete anton hofreiter
sie kann es schon vorgestellt hermann
als ex grüne und sie werfen ihm dürfen
den grünen jetzt vorkriegs stürmerin
schon über die heftigkeit mit der vor
allem die grünen nach vorne marschieren
und
verschiedene panzer sorgen beim namen
kennen und so weiteres ist neu
überraschend ich erinnere mich noch als
wir die situation hatten mit dem kosovo
ende der 90er jahre da war war gerade
frisch an die regierung gekommen unter
kanzler schröder und in dieser zeit
stand auch die frage und ich bin kein
pazifist nie gewesen und trotzdem haben
wir ja ein viertel unserer mitglieder
verloren in der zeit also dann
entschieden haben dass wir beim kosovo
unterstützung leisten das ist der balkan
krieg so wir hatten ja schon krieg auf
europäischen boden vor den letzten drei
tagen sind überzeugt dass nicht wenn er
hofreiter jetzt sagen mensch gerade weil
wir neben geschaffenen dürfte jedoch die
unfähigkeit und mehr das volk von den
ganz argument hat mich hafen sind auf
die amerikaner die seit 2014 ja sehr
viel unterstützung geleistet haben mit
der ukraine die auch waffen stationiert
haben die waffen geliefert haben die
ausbildung gemacht haben die haben
träume haben derweil die dato keine
einstimmigkeit erreichen konnte von sich
aus die ukraine nach der krim frage
sorgen in angriff kinder mutter
unterstützt ich habe das ja erlebt ich
habe damals noch diskutiert mit würden
von grün wo ich sage das kann doch nicht
sein dass die russen die krim
annektieren das geht nicht und so weiter
das ist völkerrechtlich völlig daneben
war kam aus dem grün rein oft aber
vielleicht auch von bestimmten leuten
nur na ja nee das ist ja nun die muss
man sehen die russen usw ich sage das
wird aber ein zankapfel und habe dann
215 in meinem ersten buch die zukunft
wird anders deutlich gemacht dass ich
davon ausgehe dass die mauer die deutsch
niedergerissen haben leider in der
ukraine wieder errichtet werden wird und
das können wir wollen nur nicht wollen
das ist nicht die frage sondern es ist
vielleicht ein historischer gang der
dinge weil man bei der krim eben gemacht
hat frau lindemann sie sind in schwedt
beruflich in der raffinerie auf die im
moment alle deutschen ja gucken müssten
dort spielt sich gerade er
möglicherweise in drama ab aufgrund der
sanktionen gegenüber putin werden dort
sehr viele arbeitsplätze voraussichtlich
verloren gehen möglicherweise auch ihrer
ihr job hängt seit 27 jahren an dieser
referee das war ein sicherer
arbeitsplatz dort in schwedt war wie
blicken sie jetzt darauf haben sie auch
angesichts unserer diskussion hier den
eindruck ja wir diskutieren sehr viel
über die ukraine seit vielen wochen aber
vergessen so ein bisschen ja auf unsere
wirtschaft kurze jobs auf unseren
wohlstand zu schauen er wurde bei essen
die leute schon seit ein paar jahren
dass wir immer nur ins ausland gucken
und unser land irgendwie so ein bisschen
aus den augen verlieren
so braucht die renten und die ganzen
anderen sachen die kinder sowieso ich
finde deutschland ist ein
kinderfreundliches land geworden in
meinen augen kann ja nur von mir reden
ja und jetzt sehr hoch so dass das nicht
unser krieg es tut mir leid für die
sachen die da passieren und dass da
leute sterben aber die sind ja schon
vorher gestorben da hat ja der krieg
schon 2014 begonnen und nicht erst jetzt
herr hofreiter nicht unser krieg das ist
was was man mein eindruck ist zunehmend
auf der straße hört und zunehmend mit
längeren verlauf dieses krieges
ausländer tier die kriegsmüdigkeit
während diese kriegsmüdigkeit offenbar
in der ukraine nach wie vor nicht
vorhanden ist die menschen sind tapfer
die halten weiter durch aber bei uns
kommt diese kriegsmüdigkeit
ich weiß nicht ob sie wirklich kommt
nicht meiner beobachtung nach sehen
viele leute eine große verantwortung und
würden sich wünschen dass deutschland
mehr tut aber man darf einzel vergessen
wir importieren immer noch große mengen
energie aus russland und überweisen tag
für tag millionen von euro nach russland
mit dem dieser krieg finanziert wird und
damen sozusagen ist es auch über die
raffinerie von dann auch über diese
raffinerien mann und natürlich ist es
bitter wenn man ein wirtschaftlicher
schwierigkeiten kommt und robert habeck
war vor ort bei der raffinerie und
hannemann von
fechten hat den leuten auch hilfe
versprochen sie haben auch ein hadek
direkt sprechen können und habe den
leuten auch hilfe versprochen sie das
überzeugt was ja wie gesagt nicht ja
aber der punkt ist das mag sie nicht
überzeugt haben
versetzen sie sich mal in die situation
der menschen in der ukraine die sterben
die werden zum teil ermordet die werden
gefoltert und das was dort passiert was
hier zum teil mit unserem geld und das
finde diese verantwortung kann war nicht
und sie versteht es herrschen doch 20
kriege auf der ganzen welt und das liegt
der fokus hin auf diesen einen krieg
warum retten sind dann die anderen
länder nicht und die anderen kinder die
da ich weiß ehrlich gesagt wir sehen
eigentlich aber über 10.000 kinder die
jeden tag verhungern auf der welt wo
helfen wir denn da da könnten wir schon
längst helfen haben sie wie sehen hier
gerade noch mal im hintergrund frau
lindemann die bilder von dem besuch von
robert habeck den besuch den anton
hofreiter gerade angesprochen hat den
sie aus nächster nähe erlebt haben wo
sie gerade gesagt habe das hat mich
nicht überzeugt warum nicht überzeugen
na weil sein plan auf dem papier steht
der funktioniert auf dem papier so wie
ein fußballtrainer seine mannschaft
aufstellt offen auf der tafel
funktioniert wenn dort reichen rennen
zurück weil sie glauben halt wenn das
wieder leben ins öl weg ist sind
schweden und in solch einem
wirtschaftlich arbeiten können also wir
werden maximal 50 prozent 60 prozent
auslastung haben und guckt sich doch
kinder lange an und diese versprochenen
gelder von herrn lindner der wir
angeblich zahlen sollen dann glaube ich
können wir in dieser situation hier an
diesem tisch in diesem moment frau
lindemann sagen ihr job ist im moment
leider aus unserer sicht weniger wichtig
als die unterstützung für die ukraine
schauen sie was für die ukraine zählt
ist ob diese solidarität aus deutschland
etwas wert ist rolle ob sieg ein wenig
wert ist und aus unserer sicht
alleine all den exporten die erst ende
des jahres
eingestellt werden und nur auch
teilweise viel später also deutschland
jeden tag überweist nach russland nur
für hunderte millionen euro und dafür
könnte man drei oder vier 100
schützenpanzer nachkaufen
freitag die ukraine erwartet 100 seit
sechs wochen keine entscheidung vom
kanzleramt und das ist das ist die
devise zionismus der macht die die
meinen das gleiche schuld macht ihnen
das ein schlechtes gewissen sie arbeiten
für diese raffinerien steht die gute
arbeitgeber für sie es seit jahrzehnten
und jetzt sagt der manager aber auch zu
recht davon da wird sozusagen das geld
richtung russland richtung putin
gesunken nachdem das ist ein schlechtes
gewissen wenn sie morgens zur arbeit
gehen den spiegel schauen machte mir
nicht aber ein abo kein habe gesagt als
er bei uns war der russland wird sein öl
auch an andere länder verkaufen ich
mache ja nicht alle mit bei diesem öl
embargo und er kriegt da viel geld sogar
noch mehr geld weil die ölpreise gerade
steigen also er macht nur gewinnt gesang
zu mir nur uns den russen gar nicht wir
sind die leidtragenden das ist nicht
wahr dass wir eine kosten haben es
wirklich nicht in ordnung dass sie das
sagen herr bendix natürlich haben wir
erhebliche kosten alleine schon dadurch
dass wir die flüchtlinge willkommen
heißen und versuchen so gut wie möglich
zu unterstützen
das war ihnen jetzt nicht reichen und
nicht gefallen aber es ist nicht so dass
die deutschen hartherzig sind das ist
nicht wahr die frage die steht ist viel
größer die meisten ukraine kehren zurück
schon längst es sind mehr menschen die
abreise aus diesem land die zu ihnen
kommen und ich glaube dass sie sich auch
gedanken machen sollten über die gründe
wenn ich jetzt diese runde mit mir
anhöre ich glaube das ist auch klar wie
viele programme wieso sie keine lust
haben hierzubleiben
sie fühlen sich nicht viel raum nein das
habe ich aber in dresden anders an die
stelle von ihr mit den leuten aber ich
möchte auch folgendes hinweisen sie
fordern aus ihrer sicht was ich
nachvollziehen kann aus ihrer sicht dass
die deutschen eine führende rolle in
europa übernehmen die amag hat es
eigentlich versucht aber die deutschen
wollen sie gerne mit rein verhaften der
situation ist allerdings die dass das
größte europäische land das allerdings
nicht in der eu ist irland ukraine im
krieg liegt mit dem grössten land der
welt und das größte land der welt hat
zwar auch eu-außengrenzen aber die sind
über das land angegriffen worden alles
richtig im krieg liegt habe ich gesagt
ja ich habe nicht gesagt dass die
ukraine etwas angegriffen hatte und die
wie die ganze frage der bass und seit
2014 diskutiert wird ist vielleicht ein
anderes feld aber der punkt auf den ich
hinaus will ist deutschland hat sich
überhaupt nicht mit dieser führungsrolle
befasst gedanklich in den ganzen jahren
nach der wiedervereinigung nicht dass
wir normale beschau und was sie jetzt
erwarten ist überhaupt nicht politisch
vorbereitet deswegen finde ich die
kriegsstimmung
so befremdlich das ist eine emotionale
moralische handlich möchte ich aber noch
rational bei hermann razzien ich möchte
einfach wissen was sie gerade gesagt von
ihnen sie haben gesagt zunehmend sind
die menschen die aus der ukraine zu uns
gekommen sind die fühlen sich hier nicht
willkommen das wäre für uns am tisch
tatsächlich beschämt wenn das so wäre
kann ich nicht warum warum nicht
willkommen mr
es ist eine moralische frage wie gesagt
es ist nicht für uns zu beurteilen ob
sie das ob sie uns unterstützen wollen
oder nicht dass ihre entscheidung aber
was ich heute sagen möchte ist der klick
wird vorbei sein hoffentlich früher als
später nach waffen und nach dem krieg
werden viele sich gesagt wir werden
viele sich fragen stellen wer war auf
unserer seite und
darf ich aus wie dieses jahr ist die
angst zeit ausreden nicht daran
überhaupt nicht und
ich bin kein fan von von ihren büchern
aber das letzte buch hat glaube ich
einen schönen titel das große egal und
das was sie heute jetzt vortragen ist
genau dasselbe zu treffen das was sie
was ich hier höre ist ein großes regal
von ihrer seite gegeben ich
schon fühlen sich da ertappt dass es
dass es vielleicht nicht ihnen aber ganz
vielen deutschen mittlerweile egal ist
was dort passiert dass man es halt max
it nach dass man halt weg schaut man
halt lieber herr lieber wieder lustig
macht man sagt vier monate krieg online
mit bildern wir haben doch dies brief in
die welt gesetzt den offenen brief an
das mal anzuschauen und auch mal als
kann man darüber spricht und wir sind
doch auf ihrer seite wir verstehen doch
dass sie sich verteidigen
aber ich darf sie doch mal ganz direkt
fragen für welche freiheit kämpfen was
ist ihre freiheit die ich kenne die
freiheit in russland ich kenne die
freiheit den usa ich kenne die freiheit
in kairo unter mubarak ich freiheit und
unfreiheit in russland
ebenso
brillant versuchen sie versuchen den
planeten ukraine in deutschland
anzusiedeln
das ist ihre arbeit dann manche dass
deswegen deswegen haben sie ja meine
bewunderung sie haben von uns
aktionskünstlern sehr viel gelernt erst
provozieren sie dann versuchen sie hier
stimmung zu machen und dann behaupten
sie ich sei es schuldig für jeden toten
vielleicht sogar in ihrem land diese
schuldzuweisung das reiterliche sagen
vertreter das heißt unterlassene
hilfeleistung sie helfen und sie tun es
nicht das ist ihre entscheidung aber das
stimmt
diese tragen werden ihre kinder nein nur
die eine seite dieser hass den sie gegen
ein anderes land haben den sie auch hier
in deutschland uns ja fast versuchen zu
vermitteln und diesen amanda aus
straubing oder aus bayern den haben sie
ja auch schon in zentriert aber welches
das muss man einmal das war ja schon nur
noch wenn man kinder während diese junge
frau ist schuld dass sie hat ihr ahnung
von anderen punkten ging das versteht
gerade niemand mehr wissen nicht einmal
ausstrahlen wir müssen einmal auch
lernen es gab soviel zwischen wir jetzt
diese wunderbare bei mir müssen wir
müssen einmal wir müssen einmal
aufklären hier ist wahnsinn hatte soviel
zwischentöne also sie sprechen von der
freiheit in russland vielleicht ganz
kurz lächerlichkeit einheit auf der
ganzen wir sind nicht mehr in der lage
aus diesem land zu berichten aktuell
weil es für uns gerade gesagt ich habe
gesagt die freiheit für die dieses land
die ukraine kämpft die ist natürlich in
russland total beschnitten ja aber in
usa auch nur auf eine andere art sie
haben sich abhängig gemacht weil der usa
was man da sind wir noch auf diese
position hänge also das hat sehr viel
damit zu tun und hat schon mal helfen
entschließt sich nicht entschuldigen sie
bereit wollen es geht hier um ganz
konkrete sache nicht ein demokratisches
land das defizit der hat ja dessen
korruptionsproblem ein demokratisches
land ist von einer diktatur überfallen
worden und zwar ohne jeden grund und
dieses demokratische land wehrt sich
verzweifelt
und dieses demokratische land fordere
ich dass wir das vernünftig unterstützen
und zu dieser unterstützung hören
angesichts des imperialen
vernichtungskrieges ein paar dinge dazu
fördert also erstens dazu dass man
stärkere sanktionen gegen russland macht
zweitens humanitäre hilfe drittens
entsprechende unterstützung um die
wirtschaft zu stützen und viertens
vernünftige waffenlieferung damit die
sich wehren können nämlich es ist nicht
damit getan zu sagen der krieg soll
aufhören wenn der aggressor nicht
aufhört dann hilft es nichts dem opfer
und hier sitzt der vertreter der opfer
zu sagen jetzt hört mal auch mit dem
krieg nämlich der hört dann erst auch
wenn der aggressor aufhört und das ist
etwas was wir auch ganz klassisch auf
der straße vorstellen kann wenn jemand
angegriffen und verprügelt wird dann
hilft es in der schule mal was hören wir
doch eingeredet roger sind ja schon
sowie permanente im moment ja normal sie
müssen einfach nützlich ist die nager
reden auf wären sie laut da sehen sie
müssen sie haben kein vernünftiges gegen
armut so was hat denn ihr
gegenargumenten adresse dazu zu bringen
das mit krieg der hofreiter moment in
der er als punkt auf die ganz kurzer
zwischen ganztags zwischen erschwert
oder gar kurz ganz kurz das zuschnappen
ganz als wir einen vertrag haben werden
immer schuld ganz kurz dazwischen das
ist das argument dass herr hofreiter in
dieser runde vertreten muss dass er
nämlich sagen muss und genauso wenig wie
dieser krieg auch mit waffen zu gewinnen
ist daran geht auch daran gibt es
zweifel und ich glaube auch zu recht
nach vier monaten krieg auch das aus dem
mund schwierig zu argumentieren oder
zunehmend schwierig aber herr schuld sie
müssten gleichermaßen argumentieren wie
mit einem brief oder mit briefen dieser
krieg gewinnen gewonnen werden sollte
oder auch nur behandelt
entschuldigen sie ich kann mit einem
brief keinen krieg gewinnen und sie
können hier heute auch nicht den krieg
gewinnen aber wir müssen doch
miteinander sprechen und uns nicht
gegenseitig vorwerfen was so im privaten
oder so wie sie gerade sagt meine frau
sei aus russland das sind so alles
unterstellungen darauf dass ihre frau
ist aus goslar und das stimmt ja aber
das sind so sind sie ist so ein eine
versuch ich versuche zu verstehen
also machen das machen sie bei uns in
deutschland so dass ich wirklich
manchmal glaubte sie seien hier in
seinem land tätig oder in der schule
aber herr schuld dass das ist gut dass
dieses augen gehabt haben weil der
zwischen der zwischenruf kommt nur das
transparent zu machen und dass man zu
hause dann entsprechende gespräche für
das ist ja völlig menschlich ihre frau
ist sehr professionelle geigerin und
stammt eben aus russland sie haben ganz
oft in russland ausgestellt in sankt
petersburg haben dort unter anderem
aktionen gegen den krieg gemacht ja mal
so damals allerdings mit dem
historischen vergleich gegen deutsche
panzer in russland würden sie weil sie
gerade von russlands freiheit gesprochen
haben wir können vielleicht ein foto von
dieser aktion noch mal zeigen damals
aussagen petersburg eine ähnliche aktion
heute oder morgen in sankt petersburg
machen also russische panzer das wort
der krieg zerreißen lassen dort in sankt
petersburg als protest gegen putins
krieg gut dass ich mich das fragen ich
würde das gerne bei ihnen in der
dessauer machen wenn sie die freiheit
der kunst so hoch ansetzen dann nehmen
sie mir die freiheit und ich mache das
gerne auf der treppe die 192 stufen hat
aber warum nach genau dort wieder für
das ist dass das ist das bild und die
person das bild kann ich nicht
wiederholen warum habe ich das habe ich
mit einem mann gemacht der damals noch
nicht in diesem amt war er
stellvertretender
bürgermeister unterzuckert und er hat
mit mir gemeinsam das deutsche wort der
krieg zerrissen dieser mann wurde dann
zu meiner eigenen überraschung
staatsoberhaupt und macht jetzt gerade
krieg aber und mit diesem mann habe ich
auch über den krieg gesprochen ich
glaube herr meldekette sofort kein
problem eine kunstaktion in odessa ich
glaube es gibt größere
mache ich nur es wäre ja die frage ist
ja völlig berechtigt machen sie das doch
in sankt petersburg heute dass sie da
sind tatsächlich noch aktion das habe
ich heute nicht gemacht so ich hab ja
die befürchtung gehabt und ich habe mit
diesem mann den wir nun alle permanent
venen habe ich auch über den krieg
gesprochen denn der sitzt tief in ihm
auch drin weil seine stadt wurde einmal
von deutschen fast erdrosselt und da war
auch der verräter ein anderer das war
stalin und das alles haben wir in den
90er jahren mal besprochen umso mehr hat
mich überrascht sein verhalten was ich
hier jetzt erleben wurst und dafür
schäme ich mich auch gemeinsam mit
diesem land das ich war mit gemeinsam
den krieg zerrissen habe das wollte ich
nicht können wir mal versuchen auf eine
politische ebene zu kommen wir reden die
ganze zeit nur emotional ich fühle mich
ja genau hermeling dass sie versucht
haben mal zu viel reden ja ich habe ihn
zur wache das buch hätten sie lesen
müssen dann wäre ihnen klar geworden
dass ich kritisiere dass offensichtlich
den regierenden vieles egal geworden ist
oder uns in der bevölkerung vieles egal
gemacht worden ist hat ein ganz anderes
sujet als sie gerade suggeriert haben
aber unabhängig meiner donna anna
verbergen neidinger das ist das große
land gegen einen davor hinwollen aber
mama hermenau damit soll der eindruck
entsteht hier nochmals vor interessen im
vordergrund stehen und und die
ukrainische kinder lassen sich zeigen
ich zeige ihnen ein ganz aktuelles foto
heute in der bild am sonntag es zeigt
die panzer die bei rheinmetall dort auf
dem hof stehen das sind marder panzer
und hermine fragt die mit der ukraine
seit langer zeit mittlerweile an diese
panzer da stehen die auf dem hof
sozusagen und unser kanzler seit seit
langer zeit ja wir liefern wir beliefern
libyen liefern wir haben lange listen
wir haben folgendes versprochen und so
weiter da stehen die dinger die könnten
jetzt in dieser minute werden diese
sendung läuft losrollen tun sie aber
nicht und dann entsteht der eindruck bei
einem land bei einem menschen der seit
vier monaten sich verteidigen muss das
ist denn anscheinend egal wenn die da
nicht einfach den motor an schmeißen und
die dinge ins rollen es ist ja nicht
immer leicht die rationale rolle
einzunehmen ich bin ja selber auch ein
emotionaler mensch aber der punkt auf
den ich hinaus will ist folgender wir
haben sozusagen auf geschichte probleme
die jetzt so einen riesen turm ergeben
und die einen volks richtig quer nämlich
das ukrainische volk und diese
aufgetürmten probleme sind eigentlich
seit 30 jahren nicht wirklich bearbeitet
worden das eine ist man hat nicht
wirklich überlegt in europa und zwar als
europa eigene nationale national
europäische interessen zu formulieren
dass sicherheitsarchitektur wir haben
das amerikanern überlassen die
amerikaner haben immer ihre beweggründe
offen dargelegt da hat keiner hintenrum
gefummelt das aber die sind eben in
einer anderen situation und haben andere
vorschläge obama damals mit der pacific
strategie angefangen und hat gesagt
europa ist uns nicht mehr so wichtig wir
müssen uns in china kümmern das kann man
machen aber dann entsteht natürlich die
frage wie das vakuum innerhalb der
europäischen union aufgelöst wird die
dann selber und der lage sein muss dass
zu machen da muss man doch danach
überfall ist gar nicht meine kleinen
monster abkommen über rennen hat das
minsker abkommen den versuch das in die
reihe zu bringen nach der krim
geschichte habe ich auch goutiert ist
nicht eingehalten wurden von beiden
seiten glaub ich aber der entscheidende
punkt ist für mich aber bei wofür lage
ist nicht unterlagen also geführt dass
seit nur für putin zu sein den er im
april sind selber schauen wir haben uns
das selber eingebrockt amerika schuld
oder man
macht ja ganz verrückte und ganz viele
sätze mit der jetzigen situation nur
erahnen was das problem am und im grunde
nur ablenken sich ablenken von der
tatsache dass russland putin die ukraine
überfallen hat und dass wir jetzt
versuchen müssen die ukraine zu
unterstützen und dass wir versuchen
müssen diesen krieg zu beenden und der
nutzen sie doch total sie unterstützen
die mit allen tricks lassen und ein
panzer nicht lass diarra herausreden ja
sie behaupten permanent sie würden nicht
abgesagt hat er wird weiter mit dem
getöten doch wir unterstützen auf eine
ganz andere art wie er ist schon alles
zu tun und haben ihre flüchtlinge ist
sehr positiv aufgenommen so wie sie
behaupten lassen sich ihre nation
genauso wie der hoval italien
lassen sie mich halt einfach mal
ausreden es wird das gespräch deutlich
vereinfachen und wir müssen die ukraine
unterstützen sodass sie sich verteidigen
kann nicht wie endeten krieg in die
region ziehen nur ein krieg endet
dadurch dass derjenige der angegriffen
wird sich so stark verteidigen kann dass
die adresse sich entscheidet es lohnt
sich nicht mehr den krieg fortzusetzen
und das so änderten krieg und den krieg
ändert nicht wenn wir dem opfer sagt
gibt einfach auf nämlich dann wird es
immer weiter überrollt und ich meine man
muss sich anschauen was russland putin
als nächstes angekündigt als nächstes
ist die republik moldau dann zum angriff
das kinderheim und dann als nächstes
wieder in die regierung und deshalb
müssen wir jetzt dafür sorgen dass
putins kriege enden die diskussion im
nachhinein hat liegt wir machen eine
ganz kurze pause nicht ohne frau
lindemann noch mal ins gespräch zu holen
und dazu ganz konkret die frage vier
monate krieg haben wir hofreiter spricht
gerade über das ende des krieges so
lange haben wir auch die sanktionen die
einige nicht hart genug sind fielen auch
in deutschland in der eu nicht hart
genug sind die aber ganz konkret ihren
arbeitsplatz entsteht betreffen wird
dieser krieg enden ohne ihren
arbeitsplatz
ich hoffe dass er bald endet und ich bin
der meinung dass er nicht mit waffen
endet also wir mehr waffen weg dahin
schicke das so länger dauert dieser
krieg an und mir tun die leute dieser
sterben leid tun die ukraine leid und
die russen kein mensch darf sterben und
schon gar nicht im krieg und natürlich
ist es schlimm dass er den krieg
angefangen hat aber so mit
waffenlieferungen
der nachschub aus russland und halt auch
immer sein weiß man ja gar nicht ob die
diskutieren das gleich weiter an diesem
tisch müssen wir ganz kurze pause machen
und sind gleich mit der diskussion
hierbei bild zurück
zurück bild die richtigen fragen vor
allen dingen mit dieser frage krieg ohne
ende endet auch unsere hilfe irgendwann
unsere unterstützung für die ukraine bei
uns der ukrainische botschafter hier in
deutschland andrej melik der immer
wieder gefordert hat von uns allen uns
zu engagieren uns endlich ja mehr zu
engagieren endlich die versprochenen
waffen zu liefern endlich auch ein
kanzler besuch in ihrem land zu haben
jetzt kündigt olaf scholz der
bundeskanzler genau das an für die jetzt
beginnende woche also der kanzler reist
mit frankreichs staatspräsident makro
und mit dem italienischen
ministerpräsidenten draghi zu ihnen ins
land was konkret soll kann muss dabei
rumkommen
herr kanzler hatte ja selbst gesagt er
braucht keine fototermine und auch wir
erwarten keine service da in kiew
sondern was wir oder was meine
landsleute hoffen ist dass dass der
kanzler einerseits mit einem klaren
bekenntnis zum thema
eu-mitgliedschaft nach kiew konnte und
endlich uns unterstützte um den
kandidatenstatus für diese
mitgliedschaft bei uns zu geben damit
wird auch ein langer weg beginnen für um
diese mine ist aber zu erreichen das wir
jahre da und wir wollen ja keine
hintertüren
wir wollen ein faires aber auch ein ein
verfahren um
der eu beizutreten und das zweite
natürlich ist das thema waffen ich
glaube dass die erwartung in der ukraine
sehr hoch ist das wenn der kanzler da
ist zusammen mit den makro und ein
draghi das da wir endlich hören werden
welche war von deutschland zügig der
ukrainischen hat mir liefern befreite
sie sind teil der regierungsfraktion
hören sie schon was was dabei rumkommen
wird wird dass die eintrittskarte für
die europäische union seien die olaf
scholz dort mit seinen amtskollegen
mitbringt
das entscheidet ja deutschland nicht
alleine sondern das wird europaweit
entschieden aber unsere aussenministerin
hat sich ja auch ganz klar dazu bekannt
und manche leute bringen das ja
durcheinander die denken dass die
ukraine dann sofort mitglied der
europäischen union ist sondern es geht
eher darum
sie hätte gern den kandidatenstatus dh
das klare bekenntnis der europäischen
union ihr seid ein europäisches land ok
heißt aber auch mehr ist noch nicht also
sagen ja ok also wir ja auch schreiben
da groß drauf wir wollen das aber wir
jagen den deutschen da ganz so ernst ist
ja nur nicht nein liegt in weiter ferne
liegt das heißt nicht ganz so ernst ist
es nicht sondern das ist einfach ein
langer prozess wenn ich sie müssen das
ganze regularien der europäischen union
übernehmen und deshalb ist jetzt bei
allen ländern ein langer prozess aber
auch nicht wie im moment ne ne wir
können halt sagen uns auch nicht
wirklich dass sogar eine große
bereicherung wenn irgendwann die ukraine
mitglied wäre für naja in der eu zu
haben das muss man schon offen
aussprechen das ist natürlich es geht
die eu massiv es geht darum dass
hoffentlich bis dahin ja wieder krieg
beendet ist wir es geht uns ja darum die
ukraine ist so zu unterstützen dass sie
in der lage ist die kosten für russland
so hoch zu machen dass russland
möglichst schnell diesen krieg beendet
dann geht es darum dass dann die ukraine
beitritt nämlich so ein prozess dauert
wenn es ganz schnell geht
5 78 jahre häufig länger als zehn jahre
weil es einfach ein riesen aufwand auch
für so ein landes aber es gibt auch
riesen vorteil man ist dann mitglied
eines der größten binnenmärkte der welt
und man hat natürlich auch einen
gewissen schutz also der kanzler reist
in die ukraine jetzt endlich sagt der
melnik endlich sagt auch herr hofreiter
der das viel früher auch schon getan hat
frau lindemann würden sie sich wünschen
dass der kanzler direkt danach bei ihnen
vorbeikommt in schwedt vorbeischaut
tatsächlich nicht aber
nicht sehen möchte ich jetzt sagen sie
sagen dran lastet acht bis zehn jahre
dauert bis die ukraine in der eu ist und
so lange dauert mindestens bis wir
umstellen können auf erneuerbare
energien sie müssen uns diese zeit auch
geben wir können dich in sechs monaten
unsere raffinerie die nur aus öl also
nur durch öl arbeitet auf immer zu einer
wasserstoff anlage machen geht und sechs
monaten nicht wir bräuchten auch zehn
monate und
jahre zehn jahre ich freude daran will
ich gar nicht sagen aber eigentlich
bräuchten wir diese zeit wir bräuchten
zehn jahre und stück für stück uns von
diesem roten zu verabschieden ist eine
möglichkeit das funktioniert mit
sicherheit aber wir bräuchten eben zeit
viel zeit um die ganzen anderen umbauen
sagt frau dendemann ich möchte euch doch
einmal das ist ein witz die zuschauer
sagen jetzt kommt frau lindemann
arbeitet seit 27 jahren in dieser
raffinerie für sie ist das ihr leben ihr
berufliches leben aber noch darüber
hinaus seit immer schon in schwedt für
ihre söhne sollte das auch ihr leben
werden sie haben immer gesagt mensch die
sind jetzt mittlerweile 16 die werden
auch irgendwann dort bei pck aber das
ist ein toller arbeitgeber mittlerweile
ungewisse zukunft ungewisse zukunft
jahren jetzt wollte ich noch mal zu
meinem arbeitgeber sagen wir hätten die
chance unseren standort wenn wir
finanzen bekommen ja vom bund oder von
den ländern und die zeit bekommen
bewirtschaften daraus einen supertollen
standort zu machen der wirklich alle
fantasien springt wir könnten als
vorzeige standort dienen für umrüstung
von rohöl von fossilen brennstoffen auf
erneuerbare energien wenn wir die zeit
hätten aber in sechs monaten ruinieren
werden diesen standort ja das wissen
missverständnis es geht bei den sechs
monaten nicht darum dass die auf
komplett wasserstoff umstellen es geht
darum dass sein dass die es ist kein
beispiel sein es geht konkret um steht
jetzt da es geht darum dass dann schwedt
aus rostock und aus danzig er sagte aber
auch wo genau das
ist der punkt
und es geht nicht darum dass die in
sechs monaten auf wasserstoff umstellen
sein sondern dass wir aufhören
russisches rohöl zu kaufen und hole von
woanders zu kaufen und die umstellung
auf wasserstoff ist für viel länger
geplant also brauchen sie sich keine
sorgen machen sie das ist wie gesagt
einfach ein missverständnis
sie sichern im grunde den arbeitsplatz
sie würden jetzt in dieser runde ist
fällt nicht ganz in ihre zuständigkeit
aber würden sagen im moment sieht alles
danach aus dass war lindemann den job
behält und jetzt mal ganz reines
gewissen sich machen kann und sie von
putins öl verabschieden kann polen hat
uns versprochen dass sie über danzig
gibt es eine pipeline holen liefern das
kann angeliefert werden dann über
rostock kann angeliefert werden nämlich
die pipeline die das versorgt ist die
sogenannte druschba den inzwischen
zynischen namen freundschaft übersetzt
trägt die ist schon öfter stillgestanden
wegen verschmutzung und dann ist die
raffinerie auch von woanders finanziert
werden zb im frühjahr 2009 10 ist die
rohöl wegen chlorid ist die pipeline
wegen chlorid verschmutzung ich glaube
drei monate still gestanden also das ist
nicht so unmöglich ist augenscheinlich
es hat wirklich daran uns da einfach
zwick sagt auch noch die möglichkeit
zusätzlich mit kesselwagen zu
unterstützen da hatte das halten wo
sowieso die preise schon explodieren wir
erleben einen natürlich steigen die
preise aber auch in der praxis hat es
damals aber die wir 2008 und man dafür
eins nicht vergessen ich meine für uns
geht es darum dass die preise etwas
höher wären da muss man gott menschen
mit geringerem einkommen helfen aber für
die menschen in der ukraine geht es
darum das ist scheiße punkt was wir das
geld liefern mit dem putin monaten krieg
vor und setzt das ist das rein und
dann nichts zu der ehrlichkeit hier an
diesem tisch dass sie frau lindemann
sagen dann müssen sie auf ihren job
leider verzichten weil es im moment
etwas wichtigeres gibt als die jobs dort
in schwedt deswegen bemüht sich das
wirtschaftsministerium mit alles was ich
hat
einen ersatz zu finden für schwedt
nämlich die lieferung aus danzig
deswegen verhandeln mit polen was nicht
einfach als und die lieferungen aus
rostock aber nochmal ich will will auf
das thema sie haben ja nicht die
möglichkeit die welt zu retten sondern
sie müssen im moment prioritäten setzen
ist die priorität im moment dass man der
ukraine hilft und damit unseren frieden
unserer sicherheit dient und eben damit
der wirtschaft und den jobs unter
anderem in schwedt eben schade das muss
man doch dann offen auf den tisch legen
er natürlich schadet uns das etwas aber
danach ist
langfristig schadet uns noch viel mehr
wenn wir am ende sozusagen als die
dastehen die aus kurzfristigen
ökonomischen interessen ein
demokratisches nachbarland einer
diktatur zum fraß vor aber das ist das
ist die ehrliche diskussion dann auch zu
sagen wir müssen auf diese arbeitsplätze
möglicherweise verzichten das müssen
klein deutschland herr malick den
jährlichen auch sagen nie ehrlicherweise
muss man sagen dass wir unter umständen
auch noch mehr arbeitsplätze denn noch
viel mehr wenn wir sozusagen am ende als
die dastehen die auf der falschen seite
wenn es im jahr stehen also ich versteh
ganz gut also ihre sorgen los auf ihren
arbeitsplatz aber ich kann ihnen nur
sagen also sie leben sie sehe sie haben
das glück in einem stall in einem
sozialstaat zu leben das heißt auch wenn
der arbeitsplatz verloren es gibt es
kurzarbeit es gibt viele instrumente wo
sie oder andere deutsche die betroffen
sein werden unterstützung bekommen das
größte die größte ölraffinerie in der
ukraine den chemnitzer wurde zerbombt in
den ersten kriegstagen und es waren
tausende
versorgen sich auch an greift einfach
damit ein stück verstehen wir leben
leider auf anderen planeten und was ich
sagen wollte es geht darum dass wenn der
ukraine heute geholfen wird das hat
einen preis das hat das haben auch viele
politiker gesagt also wir sind bereit
auch diesen preis mitzutragen damit
friede eintritt und das liegt
letztendlich auch im deutschen interesse
wenn putin in der ukraine gestoppt wird
und nicht weiter den appetit auf seine
feldzüge bekommt und da ist nicht nur
polen oder baltikum länder sondern das
ist auch deutschland betroffen denn er
möchte sie haben die länder österreich
wollen und er hat ja in dresden zu viele
jahre verbrachte um aus deutschland
nicht als nicht für seine russische
heimat an dass sie haben ja da war aber
nicht so
die
richtung weist ich denke jeder ist ja
inzwischen auch das ist das objekt unter
möchte 4 x com mit und band also ich
glaube wir haben ja wählen wir haben in
sachsen sehr lange und immer wieder und
das glaube ich auch zu recht zurecht
darauf gedrängt dass die beziehung zu
russland stabil bleiben das war auch in
zeiten so als russland nicht gerne
gesehen war das haben wir gemacht indem
wir zum beispiel yasni das eingeladen
haben wir haben über biologische
fragestellungen gesprochen rohstoffe
andere sachen konferenzen gemacht der
herr kretschmer unserer
ministerpräsident wird das hier auch
sehr angegriffen zurzeit ich halte das
trotzdem für richtig wenn wir eine
oberste diplomatin haben deren aufgabe
und rolle es ist dafür zu sorgen dass er
mit jedem gesprächsfähig bleibt und wir
haben ja als deutschland sogar mit dem
tal bahn gesprochen dann ist die frage
schon offen warum es auf einmal nicht
mehr möglich ist mit putin zu sprechen
dass der eigene pläne hat wird aus dem
kundigen wasser den main heute ist von
lindemann sieht steinmeier gerade gesagt
sie haben eine ernsthafte sorge dass der
mann die nato deutschland da wird noch
deutschland aber die hat nämlich
angreifen nein überhaupt nicht ich sag
nur vielleicht könnte man ja mal im
hinterkopf
sagt
er hat persönlich gesagt sagt eine
freundin immer also sie haben diese
angst sie spüren die sagen ich könnte
mir durchaus vorstellen
also ich bin kann ich mir vorstellen
dass er das machen könnte ja warum
sollte er es nicht tun und wenn er immer
von diesem aggressor spricht warum warum
glaubt er nicht dass ja auch unser land
angreifen könnte ja ist ja das
schlimmste mensch aller zeiten und da
bin ich warum reden wenn ich mit ihm
warum reden wir nicht mit herrn putin
und was soll ich den tal- und bands wie
den thalia und wurde verhandelt das muss
nicht mal vorstellen ich verstehe auch
es gab ja mal die szene im letzten jahr
als in weiß rosa an der grenze
flüchtlinge aus verschiedenen ländern
standen und provoziert haben und die
polen haben dann reagiert wie ich finde
völlig zurecht und richtig und dann hat
putin mal in so einer kleinen synthese
nebenbei gesagt da wenn das die
deutschen stört werden können sie ja mal
mit dem herrn lukaschenko reden mit den
taliban reden sie ja auch das habe ich
das zitat heute eingebracht
ich würde sagen da gibt es also ob das
eine rolle ich wieder nicht weiß ich gar
nicht aber ein gefühl und einer
ungleichbehandlung weil wir natürlich in
rot oder scholz telefoniert ja permanent
den letzten monaten ist das anders
geworden ist war ja vom letzten
heizgerät ich will deutlich machen es
gibt offensichtlich seit jahrzehnten
aufgestellt ein gefühl dass es nicht so
läuft wie man sich das denken dann
greift man auf imperiale sachen zurück
wir wollen nicht freundlich genug nein
putin hat damals ist doch absurd so
zusammenzuarbeiten meinen aussprechen
magath greift die ukraine ab weil ich
genug mit ihm geredet worden ist die
ganze zeit nein aber wir reden im moment
frage der sicherheitsarchitektur und da
hat sich europa nicht mehr die frage war
doch jene parteien am ruder ist in den
ersten 16 jahre mit ihm die welt
halt jeder bedarf
von herrn putin um das ja das ist
in dresden der sturm war schon erzählen
lassen wir denen die dabei waren hat
putin mittel maschinengewehr draußen
gestanden hat gesagt das ist russisches
staatsgebiet wenn sie das betreten dann
erschieße ich sie das heißt der mann war
schon immer so und da ist und das und
das russische imperiales
selbstverständnis war auch schon immer
so man möchte sich vielleicht mal
kulturell innerhalb europas auf
unterschiedliche mentalitäten aber so
lassen sich die anfragen zerbombten sie
lassen heilig dass wir da wo ich habe
einmal mario pohl schaffen und und sagen
dann und jetzt setzt sich weiter das ist
ja auch eine kremation jetzt lang mit
dem verweis an seine kreation war klar
dass wenn die krim in den händen da
wussten bleibt die den landweg suchen
wollen um sie zu verstehen aber
tatsächlich ganz wichtige frage welche
schuld zu doch während die richtige ist
heute abend über die schuld wir sind
darüber hinaus schon naja hier haben wir
die hat die tragen die deutschen sehr
wohl die haben das sehr wohl aufgenommen
an den die zuschauer die sind sich sehr
wohl dessen bewusst dass sie uns die
schuld zuweisen für den krieg und sie
verteidigen natürlich das land beide
nicht dagegen nicht ganz besondere der
regierungen dieses jahr weil wir sehr
schnell weiter der deutschen teilung
direkt die schuld dafür dass sie so
abhängig sind vom öl deswegen das tut
mir leid ist ihr arbeitsplatz
gefährdet ist aber wir haben nicht dafür
aber
ein stück weit
ist und die frage von denen wir uns
aber dass der schuldner kann die wahlen
werden wo sie uns kurz gewann einstellen
wir waren einfach deutschland weiter wir
waren schon einen schritt weiter wir
haben nämlich nicht nur in die
vergangenheit geschaut sondern wir haben
darüber diskutiert wie kommen wir weiter
wie beenden wir diese reden und müssen
jetzt unterricht diesen dissens an
diesem tisch und jetzt sind wir bei der
konkreten frage wie hat man überhaupt
mit putin reden so das was bei rauskommt
was ist denn die er wahlweise mit dem
behelfen was ich amerikaner er kann auch
mit den großen reden nein das war dies
das problem ist die europäer wer
bastians genommen die europäer werden
von putin nicht absolut
unschuldig aber das liegt ja in der hand
der europäer ich habe hier so mehrmals
darauf verwiesen hatte man hat ja bei
der krim bereits anfangen müssen zu
intervenieren das nicht zuzulassen dass
es versäumt worden damit ist natürlich
für die tore aufgingen ja kann machen
was er will ich es gab diskussionen im
kompass und in logan war es auch das ist
was kann ein gespräch hier sich gerade
teile des studios verabschieden was kann
ein gespräch mit putin tatsächlich
bringen haben sie den eindruck das ist
eine art dass da eine art von kompromiss
an seinem tisch jetzt entstehen kann
dass das jetzt der zeitpunkt ist das
auch putin der an jeder krieg endet am
einen verhandlungstisch oder wenn der
aggressor
besiegte wird wie es in unserem fall
sein wird wissen wir noch nicht also im
moment ist es so dass putin und zwar
nicht nur seit dem kriegsbeginn sondern
seit über zwei jahren jedes gespräch mit
meinem präsidenten der sg verweigert hat
und das war einer der gründe also dieser
sprachlosigkeit die nicht von uns zu
verschulden war sondern herr putin hat
das gewählt er wollte gar nicht reden
und hat diesen weg ausgewählt das heißt
wir wissen im moment noch nicht aber was
wir wissen und das wasser hofreiter
zurecht sagt nur wenn serbien erkennt
auf dem schlachtfeld dass er nicht mehr
weiter vorrücken kann und das kann man
leider nur mit schweren waffen erzeugen
nur dann kann er vielleicht überzeugt
werden hoffentlich auch von den
deutschen von den vermittler aus
deutschen und aus frankreich
zurückzukehren
auf diesen verrat die bundesregierung
tut sich so schwer der kanzler tut sich
so schwer den satz zu sagen dass er
möchte dass die ukraine diesen krieg
gewinnt das putin diesen krieg verliert
ist das eine illusion ist es dass der
grund weswegen er das nicht formulieren
mag ist das eine illusion dass russland
diesen krieg verliert dass die russische
armee besiegt wird es kommt immer darauf
an wie man das definiert nicht mal dafür
eins nicht vergessen es handelt sich
erfasst um ein gewisser hinsicht absurde
vorstellung
russland bombardiert die ganze zeit die
ukraine wenn mal ein tanklager in
russland explodiert was auch immer die
ursache dafür war unter umständen was
montage dann regt sich die russische
regierung
unglaublich auf während in moskau über
das leben wie selbstverständlich läuft
deshalb wie definiert man gewinnen oder
verlieren ich definiere es so dass es
der ukraine gelingt möglichst große
teile ihres territoriums zurückzuerobern
bedeutet für mich gewinnen
und große teile ist für ein wenig schon
überhaupt nicht mehr in ordnung haben
gesagt und die position von ukrainischen
präsidenten ist verzeihung herr
hofreiter ist komplett die russischen
truppen raus wieder aus der ukraine es
war immer die rede davon von der kontakt
linie vom 24 februar und was manche
leute sozusagen im kopf haben wir
gewinnen ist das ukrainische truppen
moskau besetzen oder sowas es sind
natürlich vollkommen absurde
vorstellungen so absurde aber lass dir
ruhig und jetzt kurz vor dresden stehen
das hören wir doch ja auch hier das ist
die bedrohung die aus moskau
gesagt es kommt aus dem russischen
staatsfernsehen ja aber herunter also
nicht dass lassen uns das einmal weiter
weiß auch tieren was wäre denn ein
möglicher kompromiss hennig bzw sein
staatspräsident sagt ganz klar die
russischen truppen wieder komplett raus
ja zu der linie die wir eben vor dem 24
februar diesen jahres hatten frauen ja
aber das ist ja dann bleibt der
zankapfel krim abschluss stehen und die
krim zu versorgen dafür ist der landweg
offensichtlich nötig so habe ich das
alles verstanden was ich im letzten acht
jahren wahrgenommen habe und dafür auch
immer der name mario puls und die frage
die sich mir stellt ist wie soll die
verhandlungslösung aus den
offensichtlich werden die europäer nach
verschiedenen aktionen letzten acht
jahren von putin nicht ernst genommen
das kann man mögen oder nicht mögen
erscheint eine tatsache zu sein wenn
sich das so verhält ist die frage wie
kriegt man die amerikaner und die russen
an den tisch weil offensichtlich die
leute in washington von ihm ernster
genommen werden also wäre ich der
meinung dass wir in europa versuchen mit
den amerikanern gemeinsam eine
verhandlungslösung mit der ukraine und
den russen auf die reihe zu bringen das
problem wird der zankapfel grimm bleiben
und das ist nun mal über 30 jahre
aufgebaut es gab damals und ich habe das
ja hat und 89 90 alles gerne verfolgt
weil ich das so spannend und wichtig
fand was ich die ganze welt geändert hat
für mich es gab damals das versprechen
dass die nato nicht erweitert wird also
herr geben das wird auch das wieder die
frage wenn die grün-weißen bleibt haben
sie das problem dass der landweg nicht
da ist es bleibt ein zankapfel
sie beenden den krieg nicht wie sie die
sicherheitsstruktur für europa wenig wie
sieht die gemeinsame sicherheitsstruktur
für europa aus
wir müssen schauen dorthin also wo die
wurzel des übels liegt ja das ist leider
in moskau und und es geht um ein regime
ein faschistisches regime das sich
etabliert hat in russland es geht nicht
nur um die person boten wir hoffen dass
diese dieser
staatsanwalt nicht mehr da ist aber wir
wissen nicht was danach kommt und das
heißt wir müssen uns gedanken machen
also mit mit mit der zukunft dieses
staates ist und was wie sollten wir die
diese 80 prozent der russen erreichen
die sie sind durch die baganda sie sind
die berater sie müssen an der l
irgendwie irrt wurden in den letzten
acht jahren seit der krämer sie müssen
an der stelle auf jedes wort aufpassen
frau hermenau macht eine aus ihrer sicht
wie sie es formuliert kompromisslinie
auch weil sie ganz nüchtern und
natürlich aus einer ganz anderen
perspektive da drauf guckt uns sagt
mensch jetzt lauthals seit vier monaten
dieser krieg das müssen wir irgendwie
realistisch einordnen wir sehen was auf
der krim passiert ist gibt es
mittlerweile auch aus ihrer sicht solche
kompromisslinien oder müssen sie ganz
hart bleiben müssen sie unsere position
vom 24 das nämlich alles frei von
russischen truppen sein muss das gilt
bis heute
das ziel das erste ziel bleibe dass die
britischen truppen sich zurückziehen
status quo ante 24 verbraucher ist das
alles was danach kommt das ist das ist
die sache die natürlich weiterhin im
raum steht dafür müssen die präsidentin
verhandeln können putin verweigert das
gespräch und das ist vielleicht die
zweite etappe aber zuerst einmal ist das
team das für alle klar sein sollte die
ukraine gewinnt wenn die russen sie sich
zurück ist vorgenommen und ich kann hier
nur ein beispiel sagen die russen haben
über 125.000 quadratkilometer besetzt
seit diesen 109 tagen krieg das heißt
das wäre ein fünftel einfluss der
genannten ukraine oder in
mitteldeutschland und meine frage an sie
was würden sie opfern würden sie ihre
heimat mecklenburg vorpommern opfern
oder oder brandenburg oder würde sagst
du [ __ ] opfer um
eine frage der geschichte die eine art
geschichte ist die deutschen haben
damals den franzosen in das elsass
angeboten damit sie nach dem ersten
weltkrieg vertrauen finden dass die
deutschen keinen krieg wieder machen und
das zweite angebot war die ddr
wir wollten schon mal abgegeben
und was heißt das konkret auf die frage
von herrn wenig denn er sei jetzt werden
sie jetzt jeder schenkt die ddr die
eltern meine mutter hat mir erzählt die
älteren konnten nicht aussuchen was sie
so haben wollten warum warst du was ist
was spricht dagegen dass man bei lohans
grund dann jetzt dafür dass der abstand
aber nach verstehen sie sollte dieser
schritt sollte sind jetzt okkupiert und
würden sie sagen ok damit er nicht jetzt
weiter nach freunde und nein das sieht
das eigentlich für dienstag ist doch
nicht einmal die karten auf den tisch
legen lassen sie doch die bevölkerung in
der heinz grunden was darüber abstimmen
richtig leben sie doch die möglichkeit
den höchsten demokratisch abzustimmen
was sie wollen deshalb die möglichkeit
im moment wohl streiten ist dass die
rosenheimer gehen ja das ist jetzt mein
neuer krieg aufhört wir wollen auch kein
krieg aufhört und
nach vier monaten glauben sie an die
krieg nach vier monaten ja bombenterror
dort glauben so erweist hat das ist
glaube ich nicht es geht mal was sie an
die demokratie dort glauben in denen ich
glaube dass die menschen die hand ich
habe es selber erlebt ich war mal eine
nacht auf der straße und ich weiß dass
die menschen auch in stresssituationen
durchaus in der lage sind auch für sich
selber entscheidungen zu treffen der
punkt auf die nicht als weiter kam etwas
vorhin von etwas früher von den
hofreiter hat gesagt wie immer will i am
ende nicht auf der falschen seite stehen
so haben sie heute auch intoniert am
anfang auf der falschen seite es eben
schon das werden wir dann bewerten
müssen das ist am anfang und in den lauf
der dinge nicht immer klar sie haben mir
einmal diskussion ausgemacht die nur auf
moralischen vorstellungen basiert die
kommt in europa gut an weil man nämlich
gerne verteidigen möchte wie man lebt
und wie man ist aber mehr unterstützer
unterschriften wirklich die amerikaner
und die europäer indien china alle
ampeln haben andere vorstellungen bei
der uno abstimmung hat man das gesehen
wer sich alles enthalten hat also das
ist eine situation zwischen russland und
der ukraine auf der einen seite und den
europäern und amerikanern auf der
anderen seite die ihm das sagen in ihrem
fernsehen das ist ein europäischer krieg
also das heißt die frage wie die
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
aussehen muss ist relevant das war und
in der wir uns alle etwas hin sehr
offene mit allen mitteln ausgetragenen
diskussionen die diskussion die im
moment in deutschland es genau gibt herr
mehligen macht ihm diese diskussion ein
bisschen angst kann die zur gefahr
werden für den krieg in der ukraine für
sie
tut mir einfach leid das ja dass diese
debatte man hat immer trump als als
feindbild gehabt all die jahre und ich
musste zusehen wie er dann hat das
america first prinzip kritisiert wurde
aber das was jetzt auch sie teilweise
heute vortragen ist dasselbe germany
first also wir wollen unseren wohlstand
sichern und wir wollen uns keine
gedanken machen wir müssen ja sicher
stützen aber das ist für mich das a und
das ist legitim das ist ihre
entscheidung wie können sie nicht
zwingen uns zu hell das geht nicht und
wohlstand an das geht darum ihnen auch
helfen wollen eine reine bilder sehen es
geht auch um das haben wir in der sie
wollen
genauso ist und
ja und das ist aber deswegen müssen wir
auch er ich bin dankbar für diese
diskussion weil wir ehrlich sind
miteinander sie sagen was ihnen schmerz
und ich verstehe sie und ich sage
irgendwas unserer sorgen sind und dass
wir ihn immer noch auf ihre hilfe
angewiesen sind und wir hoffen dass
deutschland diesen beitrag leistet und
es geht eben da darum ob diese
solidarität nur eine floskel ist ein
lippenbekenntnis oder mehr warenhäuser
sein denn diese waffe es geht nicht nur
um was es geht auch um das soziale
richtung denkt man sagen hören war es
nicht auch um die kollegen zu erholen
und dann müssen wir ja ich wollte gern
noch sagen wird ja gar nicht nur um
unsere 1200 arbeitsplätze die
interessieren natürlich kein großartig
aber wenn wir nicht wirtschaftlich sind
und unser unternehmen steht dann stehen
ganz viele andere unternehmen dagegen
ganz viele bankrottgehen
straßenbauunternehmen pleite dann gehen
die firmen um uns herum pleite
klickt nicht ein flughafen vom br ohne
unseren spritzen da fliegt auch kein
privatjet mehr
geld vom br vielen dank für diese
tatsächlich sehr offene diskussion
schlusswort soll bei uns vitali
klitschko haben in dieser runde den
holzhammer hat heute das interview mit
ihm geführt und hat die frage gestellt
was wünschen sie sich eigentlich was mit
putin passiert sein wunsch ist diese
antwort
die podium oder losgehen oder muss
verstehen oder muss um
liebe wort musik und musste die
liebe gott soll ihn zu sich holen sagt
vitali klitschko das war unsere
diskussionen hier am sonntagabend bild
die richtigen fragen wir sind zurück am
nächsten sonntag
[Musik]
o